salmon it's pink high in protein
Americans eat more than 1 billion pounds
a year and most of that is farmed
canadian-based cook aquaculture is the
only company operating on the US East
Coast and with demand growing and wild
salmon running out it marks a huge
opportunity for a farm able to scale in
nature salmon lay eggs in freshwater
lakes in a farm these eggs start in a
hatchery they're so small it's a huge
the temperature where they're at they'll
double in about every two weeks farm
salmon grow faster and are four times
more likely to survive than in a while
when they get big they move outside how
many Smoltz are in here right now
they're about 6,000 air smells in here
the average weight is about 100 moves
250 grams the smoltz stay until they're
18 months old and then moved to pens in
the Atlantic to mimic how a wild small
would swim from river to ocean
this is called Bronco probably a half a
mile from the coastline this is just one
file Wow with 17 pins on and how many
fish pen 25,000 the Gulf of Maine is an
ideal environment strong tides help
circulate the water to prevent disease
and eliminate waste Kukoc hwah culture
uses a central feeding system in an
underwater camera monitored at their
offshore feeding facility this prevents
over feeding the fish and saves on feed
costs one of the biggest expenses for
the company oh I see one there we go
this woman at 10 pounds the fish are big
enough to eat and wind up on your plate
in 48 hours cook is hoping to produce
160 million pounds of salmon this season
but it comes for the high cost a 17 pens
site though you're probably in the five
or six million dollar range plus
millions to build the hatchery and
thousands and regulatory fees the risk
it takes three years to raise a fish but
for cook aquaculture salmon farming is a
big business